[MUSIC PLAYING]
CORI PEELE: Welcome
to "Cloud OnAir"--
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Cori Peele,
and I'm joined by--
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Priyanka Vergadia.
Hi.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
And we're Google Cloud
customer engineers.
We're going to talk about
digital transformation
for non-digital natives
today in our CE chat.
You may ask questions at
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: All right.
So companies often have some
amount of technical debt,
whether it's ditching
that old mainframe
or it's containerizing
the applications.
So today, we will learn how
non-digital native companies
can actually start that process
of modernizing themselves.
OK.
I think we are way past this
conversation of Why Cloud.
But for the sake
of completeness,
I thought we'll go through it
and talk about, a little bit,
in terms of why
Cloud is important
and why people are
looking into it.
So Cloud offers flexibility.
Businesses today need to
scale their infrastructure
based on their demand,
and with Cloud, they
are able to do that.
As demands increase, the
Cloud infrastructure expands,
and as they decrease, the Cloud
infrastructure automatically
scales back down.
So that is-- that flexibility
is what businesses need today,
and that's why they're
looking into Cloud.
You actually only
pay for what you use,
and that's another huge
advantage of Cloud.
You reduce the
capital expenditures
when you are trying to--
you know, that server
that you set up together
or that mainframe,
when you bought it,
it cost you a lot
of money, and you
realize, later down,
that you may or may not
be using it enough.
So that is capital or cost
that you paid upfront.
But with Cloud, you
don't have to do that.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
Switch to Opex.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Yeah, exactly.
You do not have to worry
about the maintenance costs,
as well to you maintain
those licenses, to maintain
the underlying infrastructure.
All of that is taken care
of by the Cloud, as well.
Cloud providers
increase-- it basically
increases the productivity
of the employees.
So they can be
anywhere and can be
working on the infrastructure.
They don't have to
walk into the office
to actually use
the infrastructure.
And that is a huge beauty.
I think you wanted to
add something to that.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
Yes, because when
we have Clouds--
we have our G Suite in addition
to Google Cloud Platform,
and so a lot of
the collaboration
and productivity--
I really enjoy typing at the
same time as everyone else,
so you don't have to have
a meeting after the meeting
to review the notes
and then plan.
Again, everything
is very productive.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
Yeah.
Everyone can collaborate on the
same document at the same time.
And when it comes to
Cloud, your systems
engineer and your operations
engineers can just--
they can just log in to the
Cloud console and the portal,
and they can move things
around, move VMs around,
and they don't have to
be in the data center
to actually do that.
So that's beautiful too.
When you think about
disaster recovery,
and you have got like
on-premise data centers,
and you think about
creating one more data
center for disaster
recovery, you
can imagine how
much it could cost.
So if you consider Cloud
for disaster recovery,
you can basically spin up this
whole data center for disaster
recovery, but you will
not be paying for it
until the disaster
actually happens.
So that's, again,
a huge advantage
in terms of cost
and also resources.
It's also much more secure.
And the example
I would take here
is somebody, your employee,
could lose a laptop, which
could lead into losing
software that were on it
and keys that were on it.
But if you're using Cloud,
your laptop is just a medium.
It's only getting used
to get onto the internet,
but not getting used to actually
get into your systems which
is beautiful.
CORI PEELE: Oh, yeah.
And our hundreds of security
engineers and researchers
definitely help.
So customers, instead
of trying to provide
that type of infrastructure
themselves and knowledge,
they can leverage what we have.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
Yeah.
And then lastly, this is
actually the biggest point,
but I put it in the
last because you
can't enjoy the
benefits of innovation
and the technology
and the advancements
in technology unless you've
actually made that leap
and jump into being in Cloud.
You get closer to
the innovation,
you get closer to
all the new things
that the world is exploring.
And you can try too when you
are not in a silo on premise.
CORI PEELE: Yeah.
That's great.
Innovation at scale is
something we can do when
you do have Cloud available.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
All right.
So now that we understand why
we should move to Cloud, let's
consider the journey.
How do we get there?
Because today's audience is
non-digital natives, right?
So we're talking about companies
in financial sector companies
in--
or companies supporting public
sector government, in general.
And those verticals
have had a lot
of applications that
were built prior
and need modernization
and move to Cloud.
So we're going to
focus a little bit more
on those types of
use cases today.
And for those, in
order to move to Cloud,
here are the four steps.
You migrate, you
bring whatever it
is that is old and
legacy into cloud
so you can start to expand and
utilize it further and make
it modern.
While you do that, you will,
at some point, get to a stage
when you are in hybrid,
or multi cloud mode.
So even if you want to be multi
cloud or hybrid cloud or not,
you will be in that
stage some point in time.
Because you will either
migrate one application
or migrate part of your
application, and some of it
will still stay where
it is for some time.
So you'll deal with that.
So we'll talk about the multi
cloud, hybrid cloud strategy.
And then we'll walk
through, how do you actually
start to modernize an
application that's been there
for hundreds of years.
CORI PEELE: Yeah.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: That's
very key for the audience
that we are speaking to today.
And then talking about data
and analysis and what the ML is
and what all these
buzzwords are,
and where do we start in
order to modernize ourselves.
CORI PEELE: Yeah.
So in this journey,
we have a lot
of on ramps and entry points.
And so some may want
to skip and just start
developing a new application.
And others are actually going
through this ordered process
to build that core
foundation in order
to exploit the
insights later on.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
CORI PEELE: So yes
let's get into it.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So it's a journey
for those who are starting from
something that's traditional.
And if you already are a
Cloud native, for example,
or you started with,
let's say, containers,
you may be at a point where
you're ready to deal with data
and modernize, and
start doing it MLs.
So you start right at step four.
So it's up to you.
All right.
So we'll start with migration.
CIOs know that
moving to Cloud is
going to take a lot of
money, and it's also
going to take a lot of time.
And most of the times, they
are willing to invest in that.
But when you think
about it, it leads
to a multi-month-type
project and really a lot
of upfront planning.
And that, believe it
or not-- so if you
think about an eight-month's
project of moving to Cloud,
you lost the competitive
advantages of actually getting
ahead of your competition.
Well, you are going to, in
eight months, but you are--
all your resources are
doing just the project
on moving to Cloud.
So believe it or
not, it is a process
that you realize that
you will be spending
a lot of time and money on.
What if-- What if
you could actually
start reaping the
benefits of Cloud
in the week-- in the matter of
weeks and not months, right?
CORI PEELE: Yes.
Avoid spending a lot of
money and a lot of resources
and really get to
execution very soon.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Very soon.
Exactly.
So here is how Google
Cloud can help you do that.
And we have great success
stories and customer stories
on how we have helped
customers moving
to cloud in a matter
of, literally, days.
And here's how we do that.
WE have a professional
services organization
where we bring conversations
from your engineers
to our engineers.
So there's a one-to-one
engineer-to-engineer
conversation.
We start with something
called Cloud Start,
which is either one to three
days, strategic engagement
where you actually
sit with each other
and figure out what is it
that you want to migrate?
What is the first project
that you want to do?
So we scope out the goals
with you in that time.
You could decide how
big or small that is,
and depending on that, we
could do one or three days.
And then once we
have that goal set,
we go into this
Cloud Sprint, which
is really a process in which
we work with you for weeks.
Could be two weeks, could be
four weeks, depending on what
you picked in the Cloud
start phase, the project
that you picked--
it could be a couple of weeks.
And then, in those
weeks, we actually
help you create
the time line, move
from your on-prem or your
other client into Google Cloud
and bring that workload in.
So we took some time to actually
decide what you want to do.
And then, whatever you pick,
we give you-- in Cloud Sprint,
we actually move you into
Cloud with that workload.
And then, obviously,
the Secure is optional.
It's a two-day workshop for
security, risk, and compliance
concerns.
And we make sure
that whatever design
we deliver on in
Sprint is actually
secure for your standards.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
And so change management
is a big thing here
because you have a lot
of operational changes.
And so luckily, in addition
to some of these services,
if we want to work with
some of our partners
or professional
services on custom scope
after some of these
really quick ones,
we're able to do that too.
So it makes it really exciting.
But yes, change is something
we can manage and make
it really easy to get to Cloud.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
And then we have some tools that
can help you do that as well.
So we talked about the
professional services
and the hand-holding part of
it and taking you into Cloud.
There are some tools
that we offer, as well,
which can help you--
either you can self-serve
with-- for example,
CloudEndure is the
first one, which
you could use to
actually move your
migrate yourself-- your
virtual machines into Cloud.
There is-- it's literally,
when you go into Google Cloud
Console and go on VMs
or a Compute Engine,
you'll see an option
to migrate a VM,
and you just pull them in.
You can do it self-service.
You could also work with the
Cloud and your hand-in-hand
to set up a migration if
it's big or if you need help.
If you're like, I
can't do this myself,
I don't have the team
to do it, all of that,
CloudEndure will jump in to
help as well at that point.
You could also work on
disaster recovery workloads
with CloudEndure.
So it's not just migrating.
It's also making sure that if
you have a disaster-- if you
need a disaster recovery system,
you could set up that as well.
Touch on Velostrata
a little bit--
if you have a
VMware machines that
were virtual machines that
you would like to bring over
into Cloud, we just acquired
a company called Velostrata.
And you could do
similar to CloudEndure.
You could bring your VM
instances in virtual--
VMware virtual machines
into Cloud as well.
CORI PEELE: Oh, great.
Yes.
Those of you who are
on 5.5 for VMware
definitely take note here.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
And then the data
transfer appliance--
any application you try to move
is going to have some component
of data, is going to have--
it could be petabytes of data.
It could be small
amounts of data.
If you have a large
amount of data
that you want to move
over, we recommend
you use Data Transfer
Appliance, which is really
a box that gets shipped to you.
And then you load the data
out from your data center.
And then you ship it back to us.
And then you see it all in
the Cloud console showing up
magically.
CORI PEELE: Oh, that's great.
There's a lot of time for
those migration projects
where you calculate
the network bandwidth
and realize it's going to
take maybe (LAUGHING) weeks.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Or years.
CORI PEELE: Or years, yes.
So this is definitely a way
to speed up the process.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
Yeah.
And then there are
some other tools
if you just want to move
data from other clouds
into our cloud.
There are some online
tools, as well,
that we offer transfer services.
So here's what I
was talking about.
Lush is a cosmetic company,
and they are really--
it's an e-commerce company.
They make handmade cosmetics,
soaps, and shampoos.
We were able to bring them
over into Google Cloud,
migrate their services into
Google Cloud in 22 days.
CORI PEELE: That's great for
a global platform, isn't it.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
Yeah.
So that's why I wanted
to bring a story out,
just because we
could relate to it.
And that speaks a lot about
all the professional services
offerings that we discussed.
All right.
So with that, second step,
hybrid and multi cloud--
all right, so I talk with
the infrastructure leads
and with the IT
leads all the time,
and I find that the longer an
enterprise has been around,
the more complex their
systems start to get
and infrastructure
starts to get.
Over the years, they've
created applications
that are on premise, some
that are in other clouds,
some that are SaaS applications,
and all of those kind you
have to work together.
So it becomes this huge mesh of
things that sometimes gets out
of control.
And sometimes it
becomes so tightly
coupled with each other
that it's inflexible.
And then sometimes
it's so unsecure
that it's just flying all over.
And you kind of lose
control, over time.
So due to this tight coupling,
every time a new application
request comes in, an IT
manager or infrastructure lead
is, like, it's going to
take x number of days
and x number-- not days.
It's probably months.
[LAUGHING] x amount
of months, and this
is much cost until we actually
add this one tiny feature.
CORI PEELE: One--
yes, one feature.
Imagine when you have
M&A activity or--
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
CORI PEELE: --you
know, you get acquired.
And you're like, oh
great, but now what?
How do you get
everything together?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
So what if-- and "what
if" is the theme today.
What if there was a
way to avoid this?
The industry has converged to
a set of open-source standards.
And those standards
are there to address
this issue of tight coupling.
Companies have found that fully
open modern approaches, based
on containers, offer
a flexible approach
to dealing with infrastructure
and tight coupling.
Kubernetes is an
open source platform
for automating deployment
of applications
onto the infrastructure.
And then it provides you
the portability and ability
to change and
redeploy wherever you
want to take that application.
So it basically decouples
your underlying infrastructure
from your application.
So whatever the
infrastructure is,
if you decide to
change it tomorrow,
2 years from now,
10 years from now,
you're not locked down
into that infrastructure.
CORI PEELE: Great.
Avoiding lock-in and
making sure you're
open, flexible, but also secure.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
CORI PEELE: Yeah.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
And you're basically
master of your own destiny
I would like to say, just
because you made the decision
that I don't want to be tightly
locked with either one cloud
provider or with my on-premise
systems or anything else.
I can just take this application
over and put it there tomorrow.
And then, when you
work with Google,
Google offers the advanced
fully-managed environment
for Kubernetes.
So that's the advantages
you get with working
with Google Container
Engine or Kubernetes engine
because you basically just
leave all the management
and maintenance of your
Kubernetes clusters
onto Google, and you go
build the application.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
Yes.
So Greek for
helmsman, making sure
you-- we actually
do above and beyond
because we are able to
adopt the latest versions.
So those of you who
heard us say it's
really easy with
Kubernetes, but you've
been working on
your local machines
and building a lot of things
yourselves, yes, try out
the Google Kubernetes engine.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
Actually, you know what?
There is a GitHub page
by Kelsey Hightower,
and he compares
the two together.
Like, you do Kubernetes
on your own--
I think he calls it
"Kubernetes the Hard Way,"
and then you do the same
thing on Kubernetes engine,
and then you see the comparison,
like, how it's day and night.
[CHUCKLING]
All right.
So we're moving to the third
stop in our journey, which is
modernizing your application.
I have a lot of conversations
with leaders of application
development teams.
And they all say pretty
much the same thing
that you're seeing
on the screen.
Deployment agility
is what they want.
They want the ability to
get to the market, time
to market for their features
and applications to be small,
and then they want
to do all of that
without compromising security.
So in one way,
shape, or form, those
are the things that come out.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
And this is, again,
traditional, what
you think of software
application firms,
but even firms
designing hardware.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
CORI PEELE: So at the Design
Automation Conference,
we had people talking about
maybe using Google Cloud
because it helps them
with their global teams,
globally distributed
teams, and really
helps their team advance a
lot quicker and a bit more
manageable.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Yeah, exactly.
OK.
So that's where
their challenges are,
the development and application
development teams' challenges
are.
And achieving these goals
is obviously difficult
and is made more difficult when
you depend on legacy systems.
Because despite whatever
speed you want to go with,
those legacy systems
are things that we
need to understand
and figure out
how you're going to
break the barrier
and move forward
with your speed.
CORI PEELE: Exactly.
Hopefully it's
documented, and the person
who built it is still
around, but sometimes that
may not be there, but
you still depend on it.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
CORI PEELE: So now this
is what we can do to help.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
So you have a gap
between the need
to deliver the customer
experiences quickly and fast,
and the flexibility that's
offered by your legacy systems.
Now, how do you bridge that gap?
What if we said that
you can actually
bridge that gap without ripping
any of your legacy systems?
You can actually solve
that by API management,
which you see on this screen.
Apigee is Google's API
management platform,
and it helps bridge that gap
between your legacy systems
and the need to deliver great
customer experiences quickly
and fast-- get to market.
It basically streamlines
how you get your--
how you get access to the APIs,
how your developers get access
to the APIs, how
you build your APIs,
and then how you
monitor them, manage
them, make them accessible
to your partners--
not just your
internal employees,
but your partners,
your customers--
in a secure fashion.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
Yes.
And this is great for
protecting your legacy systems
because as soon as you have
a partner or some customers
demanding access to
key functionality,
let's say for your
new chatbot system,
well, you may have
this legacy customer
system in the back end,
and it can't necessarily
handle the same scale as
all these new systems.
So yes, Apigee can help throttle
and protect those resources.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And then,
for those that are actually--
that actually don't
have an interface
to be accessed by anybody--
like, I want to say access
this mainframe system.
And it has got all this great
data, but there's no API.
I can't give it to anybody,
because I have this huge amount
of data, and it's locked.
And I have no access--
no way to get it out.
And that's where also Apigee
can help, where you can--
they can help you
build a facade layer
on top of whatever
this old system is
and make it look like
it's a really nice
and shiny RESTful API that
got-- that just got built.
[CHUCKLING]
CORI PEELE: Yeah.
Yes, excellent.
So yeah, great for
legacy in addition
to new systems standardizing on
the APIs and developer portals.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
CORI PEELE: Great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: The example
that I want to bring up here
is the Chile implementation
of the national API-based
architecture.
And what they did here was
Chile had been struggling
and had tried to bring these old
health care and medical records
systems together.
And because they were
legacy in nature,
they had spent a lot
of time and money,
but didn't get the results
because the data was
locked down.
They couldn't get
it all together.
They used the API
management platform, Apigee,
and what they were
able to do was
get APIs in front of every
single medical records system.
And now physicians and people
like normal users in Chile,
who were requiring health care
support were able to access it.
And the partners
in the ecosystem
were able to access
that information
and build better systems.
So it's a great blog.
Go ahead; read it.
It totally goes with
this whole health
care non-native digital story.
CORI PEELE: Yes, it's
great for critical systems
and transformation, the
public sector level.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
CORI PEELE: Very,
very compelling case.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
And then the last step, we
are at data and analytics.
This is the step where
we need to address
that ML isn't possible without
proper data collection.
So you can dream about ML.
But you won't be able
to execute anything
if you don't have a
proper data strategy.
So in the first
three steps, you'll
be dealing with data
decisions like in migration,
in hybrid, and then
in modernizing.
You'll be dealing with a lot
of data-related decisions
with databases-- which
databases that I need?
Where should I put my data?
What is it that I
actually collect.
And then how to store--
so you can analyze
the cost effectively.
So when you make
all those decisions,
that's a better way to move
into the direction of ML and AI.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
So acquiring and
preparing the data
so you understand
what's necessary,
and then it also helps deal with
some of these machine learning
fairness activities, and a lot
of other research companies
are getting into now-- so
a great way to manage that.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
CORI PEELE: Sounds good.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And
almost all analytics leaders
we meet with struggle
with the challenge
of scaling their infrastructure,
finding the critical talent
that can help with actually
working on the data and data
analytics initiatives,
and then improving cost,
and managing the growing
expectations from the business
leaders around getting valuable
insights from their data.
So many organizations
also recognize
that artificial
intelligence will
create competitive
advantages for them.
And some are already starting
to drive AI/ML initiatives.
However, they
explore very quickly
that their current data, or
the current data warehouse,
may not be able to provide
the needed speed at which they
would be successful
at AI and ML.
So now the question is, are
you ready for AI and ML?
If your company is
not good at analytics,
it's not ready for AI.
Sorry to say this, but you need
to be really good at analytics
first before you start
thinking about AI.
You need to know
what your data is.
You need to analyze it.
You need to first be good
at analytics, period.
If you're not doing that today,
that's where you need to start.
So that's your stepping stone
into starting to do ML and AI.
CORI PEELE: Yeah.
So for a governance
standpoint, how
do you know you're
good at analytics?
Well, if you have different
teams doing calculations
for the same metric, and you
get different answers sometimes,
then maybe you want
to improve there.
And there may be a
process to go through.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
Yeah.
We recently observed a company
embracing a big data database
like Hadoop architecture
to move towards AI/ML.
But they found that
adding clusters
to keep up with the data volume
in the query data requests
became increasingly
difficult and expensive.
So there are things that you
keep learning over time as you
start to move into--
move beyond that analytics
aspect of things and data.
I'm actually going skip this
one in the interest of time.
So Google offers a fully
managed petabyte-scale,
low-cost data
warehousing solution--
a platform where you can ingest
the data at terabyte-scale
through an offering
called Cloud Pub/Sub,
which is a messaging service.
It has the ability
to take requests
from millions and millions
of different places
and things and devices
and IoT things,
and just get it
inside your system,
ingest it in your system,
and keep it as messages.
And then there is the
Reliable Data Pipeline,
which can take streaming and
batch imports at the same time
called Cloud Data Flow.
And then, as you
move along, you need
a data warehousing platform.
And we have BigQuery, which is a
petabyte-scale data warehousing
platform.
I like to say it's
SaaS, because you really
are just running queries.
And you don't have to
worry about whatever
amount of infrastructure is
required behind the scenes
to actually run that query
and get the results back.
And then, when
you're ready for it,
you have Cloud ML engine
for predictive insights.
And then a data visualization.
You could visualize data
within Google Data Studio--
CORI PEELE: Free.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: --for free.
Or if you have a data
visualization platform
of your choice, we have
connectors from BigQuery
that can just connect the
data into your visualization
platform as well.
So that's the data platform that
we've built that-- we really
believe in petabyte-scale
data platform that
is low-cost and serverless.
So most of our products
in that category
are serverless, so you
don't have to worry
about the infrastructure.
All right.
So we went through a lot.
So let's summarize
this very quickly.
We've walked through migration
of your legacy system
into Google Cloud using
professional services--
Cloud Start, Cloud Sprint,
maybe Cloud Secure--
And some tools, like
CloudEndure, Velostrata,
transfer appliance.
And once you are migrated
or migrated partly,
you're in that hybrid
and multi cloud scenario
where you want to make sure
you build your applications
in a containerized fashion so
you can take them anywhere,
and you're not locked down.
And then, moving into
modernizing your applications
using Apigee API management,
where you could unlock
that potential of your
own mainframe data,
or old data that's sitting
somewhere that's not
accessible, we use Apigee
API management platform
to build that facade
layer and make
it accessible to other
developers, partners
that can unlock that potential.
And then you move into data and
analytics and machine learning.
And we talked about Google's
petabyte-scale serverless data
management platform for that.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
And so for those who
are just trying to get
started, and you're
responsible for the budget,
we can definitely
help-- custom engineers,
professional services,
and our partners
to do TCO analysis
using additional tools.
So there's a lot to
learn, and it's great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And
we wish you good luck.
And if you would like
to get in touch with us,
reach out to either
your customer team,
or go on to
cloud.google.com, and you
will find all the
resources there as well.
CORI PEELE: Great, thank you.
And stay tuned for a live
Q&A in less than a minute.
We'll be back.
Welcome back.
And now we'll get started with
the live Q&A. Thanks a lot
for your questions.
So first, "Our executives
think that cloud is not
secure for our systems.
We deal with financial
services, and all the data
is very confidential.
How would you help me make
an argument for cloud?"
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: That's an
interesting question-- one
that we get very often.
The way I would say that
is, cloud is actually
much more secure than your
physical data centers.
CORI PEELE: Google Cloud, yes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
Well, yeah-- our cloud.
Google Cloud.
[LAUGHTER]
And the reason I
say that is based
on a couple of different things.
When we store your
data, it's encrypted
at rest and in motion.
You have the choice to
bring your own keys.
You have the choice to have
Google manage your keys.
And so, however strong your
policies around keys are,
we can totally accommodate that.
But even if you don't, we
are encrypting your data
at rest and in motion whenever
it within the Google Cloud
platform.
And then, second, we're
actually not just--
and the reason I said Google
Cloud data centers, and when
you store data in Google
Cloud it's much more secure,
is because you would
take your data--
and imagine this is your data.
Actually, imagine
this is your data
and you put it in your data
center, physical location,
and you encrypt it.
Fine.
It's probably going to be secure
until somebody hits your data
center and tries to access it.
But if it is in
Google Cloud, we've
actually shredded that data
into multiple different pieces.
And those pieces are
encrypted individually.
And then they are shipped
to different data center
locations, and then
they are stored there.
So even if somebody was
able to access or hack
one of our data centers
and get that one piece,
I highly doubt that somebody is
able to access all of our data
centers and put all
of that data together
from the shredded
pieces and make it back
into that one piece and
be able to decrypt it.
CORI PEELE: Exactly.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: It's highly--
I find it highly improbable.
So that's why I say Google
Cloud is much more secure.
And yeah, I would-- if
you need more information,
we have whitepapers
on how we encrypt data
and what our strategy
around data encryption is
and what are your
different options.
So please do check
that out as well.
CORI PEELE: Yes.
And as custom
engineers, I know we
love giving security
briefings to our customers.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
If you feel like you would
like somebody from our team
to come in and do a briefing
for your executives,
one of our team members would
be happy to do that as well.
CORI PEELE: OK, great.
And next, "We have a
few legacy systems.
Payroll and ERP are
the main systems.
We have designed
these internally,
and we are having to
spend a lot of money
maintaining them over the years.
How can Cloud help?"
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So there are
a couple of different options
here.
I think I'll say three
to touch on different--
and there could be more or
a combination of the ones
that I talk about.
One is you could just
migrate your entire ERP
system into cloud--
obviously, a huge undertaking,
but that could be one option.
The other is you basically
do a part migration.
Bring parts of your
system into cloud.
And then the third, which
in some cases works out,
is the SaaS offering, right?
If you are not using all the
systems, all the features
and functionalities
of your legacy system,
or you were looking for
something where you're, like,
I don't have the people to
maintain this old system.
I would rather pay a
subscription-based model,
you can actually also
choose a SaaS-based service
for payroll or ERP
and just not have
to worry about maintaining it.
CORI PEELE: Yeah,
so that's great.
And then, next,
"What is the benefit
of a multi-cloud or
hybrid cloud strategy?"
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: We
talked a little bit
about this, which is
containers, right?
So when you think about
multi cloud or hybrid cloud,
you're basically in the
arena where you're thinking--
or you've been on
premise for a long time,
or you've been in another
cloud for a long time--
and you're thinking,
I can't reap
the benefits of every single
thing that's out there.
And I want to actually
take advantage of that.
Every single cloud has
different strengths.
If I talk about Google Cloud,
we talked about container
and Kubernetes engine.
We are the best at offering you
a managed Kubernetes offering.
So if you were to deal with
Kubernetes and containers,
you would probably look to us.
And then, similarly, taking
an example of BigQuery.
If you want to just run queries
on petabyte storage space
and not have to worry about
the thousands of servers
that you need to
actually run that query,
you probably look to Google.
And so the reason I give these
examples-- every single cloud
has their own advantages.
So the customers that we speak
with who want to go multi cloud
want to reap the benefits
of all the different cloud
providers have to offer and
don't want to be locked down.
So that is why moving
towards containers
is an approach that
keeps you not locked down
into one particular
cloud provider
and keeps you open for
all the possibilities
that your business
might open up later.
CORI PEELE: Yeah, that's great.
Google has their really
big open philosophy.
And also, as you see
with our commitment
to open source, when we have
a great idea like Kubernetes,
we make it available.
And now other cloud providers
are able to interoperate.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
CORI PEELE: And so now,
"Legacy ERP systems
are running on physical
servers with SAN attached.
How can one cross-check
the performance
before migrating to Cloud?"
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
You want to take that?
CORI PEELE: Yes.
Because I worked with a lot
of different legacy systems
and also did a lot of work
as a middleware architect,
so this comes up a lot.
But you first need to think
about the requirements
of your particular ERP system.
So most of the time,
you don't necessarily
have limitations from
a license standpoint.
But from the Google Cloud
Platform perspective,
we offers several
different options
for compute and
storage, including
one of our recently released
beta offerings of our Cloud
Filestore.
So in addition to
SSD and hard disk,
we do have various
storage options.
But I think might be
even more interesting
is if, you are an SAP customer,
go to the Google Cloud
Launcher in the Console--
cloud.google.com.
Search for SAP, and then do
a click to deploy for SAP.
And then test the performance.
Check the versioning
to see if it matches,
and then test the performance.
So the best way for you to check
is to do a proof of concept.
And we make it very simple.
Again, you can deploy SAP
with a couple of clicks.
I think probably less
than five clicks.
So try that, and
then let us know.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
All right, awesome.
CORI PEELE: Great.
So, stay tuned for
the next session,
How G Suite Customers use the
new Hangouts Meet hardware.
And this kit lets you set up
a really affordable, reliable,
video conferencing at scale.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Awesome.
CORI PEELE: I like
having just one button
to connect to my meetings now.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]